[Music]
maybe a girl of my species and the only
one I ever saw Joe yeah he was just a
newborn what happens do I have the
plague no don't even play that just
because people who aren't getting sick
anymore doesn't mean that the world is
right again when will it be ready ken
that's balanced and you know what I kind
of like it just you and me eat you gonna
help you sir
and boy here it's mice this is my son
how many boy looking for anymore company
sir
[Music]
his bedrooms with fence no he's dead I
don't think it's a safe place to be for
me cuz I'm a girl
what do you want we commit a very cold
I've got a little job there since me
been at this a long time I wonder what
the toll is you just got to keep her
close
what if someone hurt me I'll always be
with you even if someone had met but
stabbed me and knocked me down and put
me in a block of ice and shot me in the
bottom and then I'll get up and I'll be
free
I'll come find you and I'll keep you in
your dead
[Music]
you